looking at the thumbnail okay so I'm no
blade run very few our Harrison Ford or
Ryan Gosling have you seen those abs
whatever let's review it Blade Runner 20
49 so Blade Runner 20 49 is the sequel
to Ridley Scott's cult classic Blade
Runner this was directed by Denny
Villeneuve he stars Ryan Gosling Ryan
Gosling plays a Blade Runner it's pretty
much in this world there are human
beings and there are replicant
replicants are ultimately artificially
created human beings but they're much
stronger so they're made for slave labor
in the original Blade Runner movie all
replicants were deemed illegal on earth
in Blade Runner 2049 the newer models
are illegal the older models they're
illegal in both Blade Runner films the
ones from the LAPD who find bring in or
exterminate those replicants are known
as blade runners this time around Ryan
Gosling is the Blade Runner and
ultimately he finds a little bit of
information he starts pulling on this
string proverbial string not an actual
string it starts leading him to new
information new places there is
something big at the end of this and
there are those in positions of power
who do not want him to find this out us
we have a Blade Runner movie a very
investigative Blade Runner movie and
Ryan Gosling is great if I don't know if
I can actually watch movie be like Ryan
Gosling wasn't that good I haven't seen
that lately I can't say I've seen it
really ever Robin Wright was great Jared
Leto
I feel like Jared Leto just has to be a
weirdo in every movie and this one he is
an eccentric weirdo but he's also the
head of a corporation who makes
artificial human beings the fact that
the Blade Runner movies in general deal
with the facts and the concept of what
is humanity what is a soul do they dream
of electric sheep anyone who makes these
replicants is gonna have a god complex
he kind of comes across as a douchey
like that so he was good in it
and I said before this movie is very
investigative a thing I liked it would
be so easy for someone to be like okay
Blade Runner sequel no two words action
franchise not here you get the feeling
Denny Villeneuve was like I am a Blade
Runner fan I want to make a Blade Runner
movie how a Blade Runner sequel should
be it felt like a proper Blade Runner
sequel it's a very investigative movie
one thing leads to the next thing which
leads to the next thing
all the while asking the questions just
seeing how human beings address
replicants in this world be like it
feels like you're all dicks to them but
to them they're hardwired but in the
history of any civilization that had
slave labor that's how they saw them
fools not people and Harrison Ford being
in this movie I was actually really
concerned because by the end of Blade
Runner depending
which version you watch I feel like at
the end of every version of Blade Runner
there's strong implication but you never
get this hard answer about who he is
what it is and I was scared going into
this movie because I was like I don't
want a hard answer again you get strong
implications but you don't get hard
answers you get an answer about as
strong as an origami unicorn on the
ground at the end of the first movie so
I loved how he handled that feel like
that's why he took on this whole project
he was like if I don't someone's gonna
screw that up and I like the tech in the
world his scenery and the tech just
really flushes out the world I loved
looking at this world it's really cool
to look back at the original blade run
and you're like ah so that's analog
technology in the future as they thought
it would go and in this movie they're
like this is analog technology in the
future of that future where they think
it will go put some digital Tech in here
but there's a lot of analog tech too
they kept the Blade Runner world intact
because they actually advanced the tech
they had 30 years prior through the
lenses of Ridley Scott who made it in
1982 however as much as I enjoyed this
movie the pacing in its kind of asked
sometimes which it is a Blade Runner
sequel for Blade Runner fans so the
basic for the first movies ask sometimes
- well the difference is the first one
you can reflect on and be like oh that
heavily influenced sci-fi I don't know
how if at all this movies going to
influence sci-fi and it could given the
information I have right now you just
don't know which is why I don't fault
anybody who walked out of Blade Runner
in 1982 is like I really didn't like it
it didn't become influential until it
became influential in looking back like
a masterpiece this movie's three hours
long I just didn't think it needed to be
three hours long you didn't need to take
three hours to get us there cuz even a
couple scenes in here I was like I feel
like you're setting up for something it
doesn't really go anywhere was a
conversation in particular I thought
that was gonna be a big deal later on
doesn't really become a big deal he's
gonna bum me out that was an opportunity
for some conflict who knows maybe it was
in the original cut that was four hours
long if it follows the Blade Runner one
path in the course of the next two
decades we're gonna get four cuts of
this thing and I suppose that is a
positive and a negative as much as I
love the questions of what is humanity
what is a soul neat to see but it was
also asked in the original Blade Runner
movie so the deeper things is move
you're like I have seen that before back
there are some things in this movie now
you have seen in other sci-fi films guys
in the end Blade Runner 2049 I enjoyed
it was a proper Blade Runner sequel if
you like the original Blade Runner I
think you'll like this movie if you love
the original Blade Runner I think you'll
love this movie in that if you're not a
fan of Blade Runner I don't think
be a fan of Blade Runner 2049 this movie
did everything it needed to do to make a
Blade Runner sequel which is expand on
the universe tell a story that felt like
it had to be told tell a story that was
going to be there because Blade Runner 1
happened don't tell a story that is
there now because you rearranged and
wrote and you had to make a sequel
happen because blade runners are cult
classic now just ultimately what sequels
are which is ultimately I'm sure what
this is it doesn't feel that way and I
like that I will say Blade Runner 2049
is worth watching and worth buying on
blu-ray I'm more curious know if you're
not a fan of the original movie can you
be a fan of this movie only time will
tell only you guys can tell me right
guys so Blade Runner 2049 have you seen
it what did you think about it and what
did you think of the original Blade
Runner also whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you